[Music]
that's what we should be doing we should
be chugging champagne we should be
wearing diamonds collecting albino
pythons I'm over here I'm holding onto
the poop side of this scrubber [ __ ] the
bay even is dog oil Puma has 100,000
followers the hotel we are locked down
boss party's over
I think we should turn ourselves in
what's with the pockets I'm showing them
I'm unarmed shirt off we can take them
an idea
the Stewart
my plan work cleaning work you tell me
300 kicked in the chest I'm gonna go put
on pants
[Music]
not finis we take their guns and free
the hostages
[Music]
we're here to collect a toll from Bay
Awad EP ain't touching my stacks breath
this lady just [ __ ] her pants I didn't I
did not [ __ ] my pants are you calling me
a liar you don't want someone did [ __ ]
their pants and I'm not gonna say who
[Music]
are you ready to be Tom Brady
[Music]
we do you think Tom Brady is in the
Brady Bunch
the dad right oh no use it well you
didn't bring me along to look like the
black nerd from die hard cuz I don't
[Music]
[Music]